and I definitely do take from life and I
watch a lot of documentaries because I
feel like if you borrow from another
actor that your that is imitation but if
you're borrowing from somebody from real
life then it's it kind of feels fresh
and it feels new and you know there's a
personality and imagery behind that
crash I remember like I read the script
and I thought wow this is an amazing
script man I'd normally like I'll take
breaks or whatever I'd read that you
know that script all the way through it
was really powerful and I didn't know
why exactly which is almost I mean
sometimes it's better just to trust your
instincts and I remember going back to
Chicago and my brother had just had a
kid so I didn't know what it was like to
have a kid because you know I was young
and my brother you know he was he was
always like you know never had trouble
with the ladies and always like you know
one of those dudes that combed his hair
and like his hair looked like it was
bulletproof you know like always dressed
really smart and you know I go to his
house and he's like hey Mike what's
going on his hair is all disheveled look
what's going on buddy and he's like dude
look how beautiful she is man and and
he's like he stopped it's not like you
stopped caring about himself but his all
his attention went on the kid I was like
wow that's really interesting so I just
spent a month with those guys and then I
took whatever that was and it's a subtle
thing but it's a thing that was really
important to me especially in that movie
like crash when I'm talking to my
daughter and have no attention on myself
whatsoever and so that's what I took
away from it and I remember telling Paul
Haggis because I read it in a book think
about Buddhists and Buddhists like they
believe that you're here for you know
for lifetimes and so you wouldn't treat
a child like a like a child right you
treat him just like a guy tomorrow I was
like what if I do that and he says yes
that's good that's good that added
element of vulnerability for the guy to
be embarrassed about telling you know
the story about the ferry ride you know
going around and then in the room and
then you know this ferry give him an
impenetrable cloak invisible cloak when
I was five his favorite came into my
room one night she I told you weren't
gonna believe me okay go to sleep now
you little rat and those were the two
elements and I thought were very
important I don't know if anybody picked
up on him but like for me that's I was
really important
oh yeah I uh my sons nine years old but
now I'm oddly enough I rewatched crash
and I was a crying little baby man
because I was like that's the word like
you're you know the worst nightmare to
you know to have a kid potentially die
so now I get it like why people were you
know affected by World Trade Center
after crash what happened was that I got
a phone call from Oliver freaking stone
and that he wanted me to read a script I
was like what is going on and like right
after crash I worked on crash I was
basically I was a musician I'm touring I
don't know if this movie thing is gonna
make it because I'm like I'm being cast
as gangbangers I'm like okay so I get
this call from Oliver Stone saying he
wants me to read this his office wants
me to read this thing called World Trade
Center and and so I read it I can't
believe the story and it's you know
starring role holy cow
I'd be opposite Nicolas Cage holy cow
leaving Las Vegas you know raising
Arizona I I did the movie and and I was
freaked out because you know I the most
I did was worked on crash for four days
so from four days to run of picture
which means that you're basically
working almost the entire time and you
have so many scenes I was like wow this
is such such a big step up from that
gradient i I didn't feel all that
comfortable but I just kept rehearsing
and rehearsing and rehearsing rehearsing
and you have to understand it was like
10 years of just doing it parts trying
to do the best but like how and like how
good can you be when you're like over
there that's your line
you know and the movie did well I mean
it did pretty good here in America I
think it was like it might have been too
soon for it but it was like it's a
really cool movie and but it was just
working with Oliver Stone and like knock
on wood you know hopefully I get to keep
working with those kind of guys Million
Dollar Baby it was so awesome shooting
with Clint Eastwood Clint Eastwood man
I remember watching all his movies my
dad used to sneak me up and you know
we'd see like Heartbreak Ridge or
something like that I told my dad I was
like dude I'm doing a movie at clinics
when he's like tell him I said what's up
he'll know I'm like no I won't did and
so I was on set for three weeks man
which is another blessing and I was just
well I just watched away like movies are
made and he was a master there's so much
to learn about acting and so it's it's
almost like to me it's like chess where
if you do something here you set up a
thing here like it really affects you
know the end game and you really have to
think three or four moves ahead
grandmasters like the the best you know
guys a Grand Master looks at a
chessboard and there's only two or three
vital moves and which is the which is
the one that they're gonna go to the
which is the one and they're always
seeing like two or three moves he's one
of those guys I've worked with him just
recently again again it was that you
know somebody would pitch him an idea
and he's like now yeah I don't think I'd
want to see that I think I think this is
nice this is nice and boss says it and
then you look at it on the frame you're
like it's pretty good
anything else will take you away from
take your attention away from that he
reminds me kind of like a Ridley Scott
in a way like all the the established
directors and the really really good
directors they don't shoot like all day
you know and me because they know
exactly what they want they're really
are masters at their craft and and
Ridley is more like more like he's
building an opera Clint is more like
jazz you know what I mean but it's still
pepper
the Martian I remember I I got a phone
call that Ridley Scott wants to meet me
it's like wow that's really cool
you know we're actors but we're still
fans of these movies like I'm a huge fan
of Ridley Scott so I was kind of nervous
I saw that he had he kind of like
already had all the drawings mocked up
for this for the Martian and he also I
think he might have a photographic
memory I'm not sure because if you talk
to him about a scene
he knows the dialogue and he knows
exactly what you say you needed knows
what number and I'm like you pitch him
an idea and he said yeah that could work
you pitch him another idea and he's like
yeah but it's remember you're setting up
this and this you feel very comfortable
there was there was a scene where the
you know something was shaking like the
ground was shaking and he shot the
rehearsal you know he didn't tell us it
was gonna shake so everyone like you see
the real reactions from people and you
can't act that I wasn't that bright
because there was a couple times where
I'm like what's up with this sign it
keeps on shaking man and I up my part of
the of the take or whatever observe and
report I feel like that's a very like
I'm still Seth Rogen's line but I feel
like that's a very polarizing movie
where people either love it or hate it I
auditioned for some comedies but I was
like I never felt really comfortable and
I never really felt like I can I felt
like I was boring myself so I I thought
what if I do characters cuz I like doing
characters like real characters and then
so that it if it's not funny it's just
the way the guy thinks and if it is
funny then whatever this is Who I am
the part the one that I got no on that I
made up is uh I remember watching this
this documentary or YouTube thing or
whatever on pimps was this little guy
you know and you pan up and you see a
like oh he's in the vacuum interest is
in his bedroom and then you pan up and
you see some some dress shoes and those
dress shoes are on the bed and you're
like in the dress shoes are kind of
dirty and then you pan up and there's
two women they're two prostitutes and
one of them is just filing their other
nails and the other one was just chewing
gum like when is this gonna be over and
then you see the dude and you're
expecting him to be like some stud or
like some crazy and he's like just this
little guy you know the high-pitched
voice the documentary guy the one who's
doing the interview just totally tease
him up he just tosses it out there and
he's like hey brother you got to tell me
man what's the secret to pimping and
he's like man you got to love your
[ __ ] I was like man you gotta love
your brother you know and the girls
didn't do anything I was like whoa
that's a character right there buddy
and then so I thought wow it'd be great
to put this guy in a movie and then
observe and report came up I'm real glad
that you opened up to me because it
makes me like open up my heart that was
the start of me channeling somebody else
I think that was my first commuter groan
ant man you know Edgar Wright wrote the
original script and he was gonna direct
it and then he parted ways but he left
the script and he got me he's the one
who wrote me in it because he he saw
some of the oddball comedies that I did
and he loved and it was his idea to put
that odd ball on a ball character into
the into the movie
I was trying different characters and it
just wasn't blending in with the entire
story and then the day before filming I
was like wow wait a minute
and I remember that just do Pablo from
my old neighborhood like he has such a
different cadence and you know I
remember I asked him one time I was like
what'd you do this weekend he's like how
about today about like he's like what
I'm out you know fan out I'm not there
anymore so good that and then I reread
the script with his voice in mind I was
like that could work
hey how's your girl man oh she left me
oh yeah my mother too you know we would
do a lot of improv and the improv for me
it was just me talking and and sometimes
I would forget what I wanted to say and
you just go streamline of consciousness
you know he's like yeah but I went
downtown I couldn't find a parking you
know but but you know I I saw some
people sounds with tacos and I was like
man I remember tacos cuz back in the day
I remember it was like in seventh grade
when I had my first taco bus door I met
this girl and this girl was really
beautiful and she said to me what he
like up I'll store him like why not and
so anyway I dated her we got married she
got divorced but then anyway so I was
like I was parking and then like you
know and I was like oh yeah I'm so let's
go back to parking right and I was like
so I was parking and I'm like that's
that's why I'm late you know like what I
was at a wine tasting with my cousin
Ernesto it was mainly Reds and you know
I don't love red as man you know but
there was a rose a they say today it was
delightful and he tells me about this
girl Emily that would used to kick it
with it was actually the first pair of
boobs that I have a touch to wrong
details you know Marvel's dude they're
so awesome
they'll take whatever you what do you
whatever you have and then if they like
it they'll just run with it that
character was so nerve-racking for me to
do because I it's mainly the dialogue
and it's so much and it's so fast and
that's probably though to be honest with
you the hardest character that I had to
do and the watch I read the script and
the watch
nobody said anything really about it
they said no this cool script came by
and I'm like check it out okay cool I
read it we weren't getting paid and we
were getting paid scale or something
like that so like that's what that's
what the movie was cuz it was a
low-budget movie I read it and it was I
remember it was one of those scripts
that I was like dude what's going on
with this I'm like can i audition for it
when is one of like an audition end of
watch i imitated
there's a there's a buddy of mine who
actually talks like this it's really
quick and then all of a sudden no
problem
what about whatever and so I was like
wow I'm gonna do that for this character
I got a hell a big family bro
someone's always at my house right well
one time Gabby's parents bounce Ensenada
and her brother crash at his girlfriend
so I spent the night at her house and
this was gonna be the night dude and I
remember going in and and meeting uh
David Ayer and he says dude you got a
like this isn't pretended you got to be
brothers you guys got to be brothers
every like every day for like three
months just hang out dude until like you
get annoyed of each other until you
could just be bored you know what I mean
you don't have to feel like you have to
entertain each other and it was really
cool cuz he was such a he is such a
dedicated actor of all the people to
help me he was the first one to really
say do don't want dude this is Jude do
it man this is your scene man I was like
oh that's so cool any scene there's any
scene where he's like dude this is your
scene man take it he was really just
cool about that you know because at the
end of the day he's the movie star and
which you know shows that he's really
all about the movie he was he was just
so dedicated and passionate about it and
to me it was awesome I loved work with
the guy but I had him and David Ayer
supporting me in that and then I felt
really free I felt his freedom and that
was the first time that I was like okay
maybe I feel comfortable you're starring
in things fury david ayer called me up
again and he says dude I got a script
for you and and whenever you you know
I've seen some there's some actors that
like are good performers and they do his
movies and they're really good and then
there's guys that like have to dig in
like I have to dig in and like really
feel like I'm the character so your
heart always pumps you know you think
man what does he want me to do this time
what hell does he want me to enter and
and then I read fury I read it it was
amazing part was really cool
even just me being there even if I
didn't have any dialogue but I was part
of the five big crew representing the
Latinos that were in world war two
because there there was a lot of them
that were just unacknowledged even you
don't see that at all even just being
part of it would have been an honor but
he rewrote a great part and and I was
you know part of it and you know Shia
had a great part you know low and Lerman
Jon Bernthal Brad everybody had a really
cool part and we were all just crazy in
that movie because you know you have
you're sleeping by the tank and just
like there's there's something and it
happened because it was so cold and so
crappy it was just something about like
it just sucked so bad that you're like
screw it whatever it was kind of
apathetic like you do let it rain brain
warm cool who cares and you're cold
you're your body shaking is like
whatever did like we went through in
comparison with what like the guys that
really did it there was no room for
complaining I drove a real tank I
remember it took me like a month or two
to to really to be good at it and I felt
like I was good at it but when you have
like Shia LaBeouf and you know Brad Pitt
up on top like others big movie stars up
there I don't want to kill them
Cesar Chavez my parents were farm
workers and they came from Mexico to
Chicago where there's a lot of factories
and a lot of work that people don't want
to do but they did you know they were
good they were there were good people
you know they learned a language and
they they you know definitely subscribe
to the dream of being an American they
worked their butts off to get me and my
brother through prep school private
school and so and obviously because I
love my parents when this movie came
about I thought wow I just can't miss
this opportunity and but it's a very
Latin movie you know with a movie like
that it's hard it's hard to make it
Universal and so it was a tough movie to
make but I'm very proud of it and my dad
was very proud of it as well
that's why you make certain movies you
know certain sometimes you make movies
for the masses you want something to
have a good time and sometimes you do
think pieces because you think of like
they're you know this movie might bring
up a really cool issue and you don't
have to talk about to your shoe if you
know if the movie says it for you